L'île Georges, un site
historique national et
le lieu d'emprisonnement
d'une centaine d'Acadiens
avant leur déportation.
C'est cette partie de l'histoire
qui en fait un lieu d'importance
pour les Acadiens.
MARIE-CLAUDE RIOUX, directrice,
Fédération acadienne de la N.-É.
- On connait les conditions
de détention des Acadiens
sur cette île. Il y avait
aucun abri, il y avait pas
de rations, ils étaient livrés
aux éléments. Certains sont
morts de froid, de faim.
- Un triste chapitre de
l'histoire qui fait en sorte
que plusieurs Acadiens
aimeraient bien se rendre
sur l'île pour se recueillir.
Mais impossible de s'y rendre
sans l'autorisation
exceptionnelle de Parcs Canada.
Cela changera l'été prochain
avec un financement d'Ottawa
de 2 millions de dollars pour
la construction d'un quai
sur l'île et 1,6 million
de dollars pour financer
l'encadrement des visites.
Car l'histoire fait en sorte
que l'île intéresse aussi
les Micmacs, qui fréquentaient
le lieu bien avant que
les Anglais y construisent
une base navale. Les visites
de l'île pourraient donc
intéresser beaucoup de gens.
- On veut pas que ça,
ça devienne un carnaval, là,
derrière. On veut quand même
qu'il y ait un certain respect
puis que ça soit quand même fait
de façon respectueuse,
les visites sur l'île.
- La Fédération acadienne espère
travailler avec Parcs Canada
afin d'élaborer les visites
sur place. Parcs Canada est
ouvert à l'idée.
"On compte travailler de près
avec les Acadiens et les Micmacs
afin de concevoir l'expérience
des visiteurs sur cette île",
affirme Eric Nielson,
responsable de l'île
pour Parcs Canada.
Les visites de l'île Georges
devraient commencer lors de
la prochaine saison touristique.
Ici Paul Légère, Radio-Canada, Halifax